what's going on there reject nation greg
and john here today we are going to
start chucky we saw so many comments
coming in leading us to believe that
there will be so many people who want to
check out our reaction let's see how
wrong we are
what i asked right now is if you go and
hit that like button because it's the
number one thing that helps us out in
the algorithm subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our reaction for the next chucky episode
is up and i want to mention too that now
is the time for jon to truly shine oh no
what do you usually say yeah i've
dabbled in chucky i've seen some chucky
i've never been messed up but this is
john's time expertise time he knows so
much more than i do about the chucky
world she better catch everything every
everything you carry chucky i will not
be reacting facially or auditorily i'll
just be pointing characters and that's
your job today john i'm gonna do the
easter eggs your hour finally some
horror that's relevant you got this
full-length watch alongs where you sync
up with the time code or over at our
patreon page cover a whole bunch of
shows are there at the same tier
reaction highlights and watch songs
included and this time we got our buddy
nerd chronic returning to help edit down
these highlights for us give him a
follow he's a wonderful dude let's get
into it
[Music]
it's like uh
the opening of halloween yeah exactly
what
okay
you went to vintage no i'm in the retro
oh what's the difference about 10 bucks
fair enough
someone took the butcher knife
wonder who hackensack is a haven for the
bizarre the [ __ ] up and the straight
up criminally insane we haven't seen
this kind of violence here since the rey
family murders in 65 a bloodbath that
gave birth to one of them charles lee
this is devin evans bringing you
slash
nice podcast name the podcast
yeah
absolutely
this kid's got a full radio [ __ ]
like what is this town
he's an outsider like the outsiders
no that cat's gonna die huh
cool
no no
no you remember take your pill today
oh yeah no you should take it
you're gonna need it your cousin's
coming over for dinner remember oh [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is right
this guy's just the bearer of bad news
yeah
so how's business
that's not what we're talking about sure
it is there's no shame in getting a
little help now and then who's ashamed
you're my brother
you do the same for me they do look like
a lot of like are they twitter they're
the same factor i can't tell if they i
think they just copied devon saw
you're gonna need another
extracurricular
harvard's gonna want three it's
definitely the same actor yeah that's
how by the way
yeah
i don't think davidson was a real
brother
now you should totally come check it out
junior
what it's true
would you give it a rest
i would never visit this man
i know family does not mean that enough
enough to visit
to go sit through an awkward drunken
dinner
oh they're gonna think he did it
[Music]
lucked out this time
here banks
zachary banks
yeah
what the hell man damn it dude
no more dolls jake
ever
literally shattered his dreams yeah
right in front of him
hi i'm chuckie i want to play oh my god
that's adorable
say cheese i can't wait till you die
well actually i'm going to sell you're
selling your stuff now jake
i didn't realize it'd gotten that bad
you can venmo
being financially disadvantaged is
nothing to be ashamed of jake right
not oh she's way nicer than i expected
her to be yeah
subverting expectations
maybe you should give the guy a break
don't go stop to me babe
oh never mind she's gonna die
chucky's going to help him pass his
class
oh no
a little excessive i love all the split
die after shots though
what is going on
lexi's new gofundme
that's mean here you go wheeler
don't spend it all in one place
discipline that boy come on miss frizzle
well i was wondering maybe you'd be
interested in coming on my podcast oh
hell yeah
what i want to do a whole series on
bullying jake oh no i thought you're in
a true crime bullying is the truest
crime okay do you love that the poster
boy delusions to you no i don't know i'm
not interested i gotta go
in my pocket
get to work
come on buddy
hell yeah
oh
i rehearsal not so fast i want you to
tell mrs mcfay what you told me i'll
take the page down okay i have to go i
think i lost my phone just keep an eye
out for it
i gotta stop smoking so much weed before
class
hello yeah i'm calling you about the
doll
that was fast is he there with you now
no he's serving storage is his name
chucky
yeah
was this andy on the phone
that's the first movie
i'll do the trick yep
definitely won't find his way home
didn't just make his way from your
perimeter school all the way back to
your home
[Music]
why don't you pick on someone your own
size
my man come on chuck
hi
i'm chucky
and i'm your friend to the end
now i said friend jake
nothing more
not that there's anything wrong with
that
yeah you should know
look what i found
my phone
that's pics of oliver too
oh
oh
guess that was a secret
[Laughter]
she's into pokemon corn
oh no
look but she keeps googling
why do my farts smell so good
yeah chucky
takes me back to the old insult show at
universal
oh
someone's gonna want a good guy doll
you're all a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
let's go i'm out of here
[Applause]
way to go chucky
he knows how to
hack a cell phone
yeah there's not much charles lee ray
can't do
you insulted your friends and your
family
in front of the entire school they
deserved it it doesn't bother you that
everybody thinks you're [ __ ] weird
huh you don't care that they think i'm
weird
you're just good that they know i'm a
[ __ ]
you see that again and i will kill you
you hear me
you hear me god i hate this guy so much
sean from boy meets world that's who he
reminds me of i could not pinpoint it
[Music]
that's a hell of a spider to have
little step steps
no oh
yes
get to work
go chuckie
my man
dad
how dad are you are you doing some
frankenstein experiments down here
come on now
flashing blue and red like the colors
spiderman spiderman spiderman crossover
i think you're in the same class as my
son
oh snap
that's right i already know so much
about crime yeah
oh hey man the good version of my dude
you couldn't have done that before you
what happened to your nose
i fell
oh i'm very sorry for your loss
what's wrong when the minute and your
dad hit you yeah
every kid just hopefully admits that
right
yeah yeah it's really easy just to talk
about that right off the bat
especially hours after he's just died
yeah every kid is so open about that
yeah
hi
i'm chucky
and i'm your friend to the end
heidi [ __ ] hoe
yeah this is awesome yeah
i didn't want him dead what did you
think i was gonna do ask him for a hug
after my mom thought he just
he couldn't deal
oh i thought we were talking about the
cat
let's talk about that [ __ ]
let's
see hug
[Music]
charles
[Music]
thanks for the messages
what a show that was awesome nice they
got a rack of puppeteer credits too that
was very enjoyable holy crap yeah that
was like so much fun
that was a lot of fun
i was about what i wanted it to be i i
like that for its first episode they
don't show too much of chucky's
movements obviously as the show
progresses we'll start seeing him you
know walk around a lot more and have a
lot more dialogue but they're they're
thrusting you more into the perspective
of jake for this time around
so to have like the the movements kind
of just appear in the background or have
it be like that puppet move have that
kind of mood about it i think is a
really
smart way to go about it all
and
yeah i mean it's chucky you want to set
him up in a way where he's going to end
up killing a bunch of people
and so let's have our main character
just have no one good around him not now
one
individual it's it's a it's but it's
like the
the personality of it because it's
ridiculous to the point of just like wow
like no one looks after this guy really
the lab teacher kind of did
but further even at the auditorium
people are calling him loser and then
you see parents in the background behind
him
this kid is a loser he's a loser that's
the way it is being a kid must be a
loser freak lost his mom you know he
looks [ __ ] like that but there's uh
there are there are uh additional
nuances and layers through a lot of it
especially with your protagonist
character but
uh yeah man
overall quick thoughts i would say that
this was a this was a really amusing
amusing show it had had a bit of the
vibe of a movie that i saw a couple
years ago called tragedy girls
uh and
yeah like i like it i want i can't wait
for all these
[ __ ] to suffer anyways you know what
you think yeah i really enjoyed this too
i mean it
chucky child's play the entire series
has had so many different tones i mean
you know you start out in a horror
environment by the middle you get to
complete parody and i like what they've
been able to do bringing it back around
with the more recent films and now this
show is you're kind of splitting the
difference where you have a lot of that
kind of
gleeful
uh energy behind the camera you have
that sort of uh
foreboding but in a kind of
uh grinning way it's the best way i can
describe it at the moment and uh i like
that yeah they've split the difference
where this is really fun really
enjoyable and chucky definitely
maintains his attitude and then like i
said during the talent show i flashed
back to the old chucky insult show that
they used to do at universal like you
know they was great where they can that
canceled culture
pre-canceled culture cancer culture that
was the little nebulous of cancer
culture right there right chucky's
insult show and then i got on the
internet and that show quickly
disappeared ah man you got to find that
that was it was hilarious yeah but i
attended several times it was funny i
was like why is he picked on me yet
come on chuck uh but yeah i really like
the cast overall uh i liked the chucky
the yeah like the way they're handling
chucky not you know clearly we know
uh so they don't waste too much time at
least showing his eyes move around and
stuff like that but for
the greater extent of slasher kills and
stuff it seems like they still have a
good amount to build to and i really you
know got endeared to the jake character
and i like to like you know don mancini
the creator of this franchise is a gay
man and so oh is he yeah and so uh and
it's cool that you know after all the
rights issues and everything to see him
you know he wrote directed and exec
produced this episode and then the show
generally um so yeah to see that
perspective come in in a way that feels
kind of authentic and feels like it was
authored by someone who might know it
feels personal yeah it was also just a
nice touch because you know the the more
movies and hollywood and shows get
conscious i feel like characters get
thrown in to fill a representation quota
and this yeah felt like a really natural
place for the lead character to be
coming from and i found myself
appreciating the little looks and
moments and the little
interplays that would create between
characters like i didn't expect to
actually be kind of into what was
happening with the characters both on a
sympathetic level and two on the level
of you know the ones that you want to
see get their comeuppance and you know
they draw
they they do suffer a little bit of that
like where is this is anyone going to
discipline anybody but at the same time
it's not so stephen king ridiculous that
it's like taking me out and breaking the
world and i think it maintains that
level of
okay these
people are
[ __ ] enough that for the tone of the
show we the audience will have fun
watching their fates come around it's
funny that the the opening scene the the
the book ends of this make you think
that's all it seems like a definitive
homage to halloween yeah and
lately with the halloween franchise
michael myers comes home and now they're
doing chuck he comes home and we're
going to learn like his backstory yeah
alluding to that the ending of what led
charles lee ray to become
the serial killer that he is
which is
interesting i mean i feel like at this
point yeah why not let's learn it let's
have fun you got to show we can explore
it
um but yeah as you're talking about with
like the characters i did find it
cathartic and i love being put in that
position like that it's messed up that
talent show what he's doing but i am all
on this guy's side right now yeah
humiliate them
humiliate them yeah for the part of you
that's been subject to that kind of
treatment this is that little catharsis
of like oh i wish i could say all these
things i don't necessarily want to kill
everybody but i wish i could you know
really get one good on them i i actually
i i was i was so kind of quickly
adjusting to the
the tone of the show really fast that
the thing about him being gay surprised
me
because
i thought it was just going to be like
cliche tropes the whole time that's like
there were parts of it that are cliche
tropes with the characters in the high
school
and normally it would be that he's not
gay and that they're just being like
but he's not like you play with dolls
yeah but he really he like has a crush
on some girl he has a crush on junior's
girlfriend yeah there's some some [ __ ]
like that right so i like the fact that
they did keep him gay and then they he
does have chemistry with that like devin
is that the cute guy's name
the guy with the podcast
hack and slash
yeah that's cool like a little kid
having hard things about it that would
make me think of the reboot of the
halloween yeah especially with the
podcast too but yeah yeah yeah well and
hopefully i mean hopefully he comes in
handy maybe and doesn't meet the same
fate as the true crimers in uh halloween
yeah but 2018. but chucky has a
supernatural element i mean the very
idea of supernatural the opening scene
of child's play who like when he oh yeah
he abused his body
yeah and one supernatural then there's
been even more added to that you know
like charles lee ray's soul has been
split into multiple pieces and there are
multiple doubles and blah blah that's
why having a world that feels more
hayden especially a tv format it's a
it's a perfect tone to strike and and i
love the style that's brought to this
at least in this pilot i i think it's
the style is really well executed
and i was engrossed in it yeah and i
think the character of zachary i love
what they did with the dad here because
the dad is just
so he's
someone who's incredibly resentful of
his son i'm sure like you can feel the
layers that the actors provide of
mom died maybe blames his kid in some
way or at least sees his mom the thing
that he lost in his son and there's a
line there that alludes to that which
only hurts his pain more he's not a guy
who goes to therapy and [ __ ] deals with
his crap
but even for zachary you know that i
thought it was a real human thing when
he's talking with chucky
to be like he wasn't like that when i
was younger like that's where his
grievance is taking him towards of why
he can't just be like yeah my dad was a
dick he deserved to die because he holds
on to the memories of when he was good
and what it used to be and it's his dad
it's it would be a conflicting death
even though i'm sure
there's a sense of relief that
the monster who he's domesticated with
is now gone you know yeah now he's got a
new monster today investigators up which
is going to help him out
father figure potentially i mean chucky
might rub off on this guy before the
show's done
there's some human qualities and then
the was the last chucky movie the one
that dealt with them and the like the
the cults of chucky's the group meetings
yeah the one in the uh the mental
hospital yeah that that in cursive
chucky kind of brought it back around to
being more of an actual horror movie and
less of like an overt horror comedy yeah
yeah yeah and uh and yeah i mean i'm
curious to see what returns from that
side of things because i mean fiona durf
it was in the last couple movies and i
mean she's got to join the show at some
point yeah but i i did like the
how this show just kept hopping back and
forth between two perspectives which was
chucky's perspective
which was a cool subtle thing to do
because of the fact that it's like the
audience knows chucky's alive and
they're not trying to hide that at all
they go right to the eyes to highlight
yeah they're not doing like this major
reintroduction the whole point of us
being here is we know what chucky does
yeah yeah yeah and if you're watching
this show you probably have seen a few
of the movies or at least one or
something to to get an idea of what
chucky is so i like that the show is a
self-aware
of that but is not being a spoof of
itself absolutely which i think makes it
such like some of the films have been
yeah you know a thousand percent um i
was i was impressed i i was more
impressed than expected to be because i
had a feeling it would be good but i
wasn't expecting to be to find it such a
cathartic thing and to be like oh i like
this man this is such a complicated
situation for this kid to be in because
he is treated so
horribly and i think you need it to be
that ridiculous yeah you need especially
when you're gonna have chucky your doll
who's gonna be picking off people for
zach you have to have it be just to the
max of wow i've
like this seems from such a different
generation because i thought that would
do like a 21 jump street thing
when the when he's talking with the
blonde [ __ ]
and she's like oh do you need help with
my like where she's i genuinely bought
this yeah i did so i thought they were
doing some type of subversion of like
we're gonna do the tropes but we're
gonna surprise you and flip [ __ ] and
come to find out no she actually is a
[ __ ] so
in that regard though i'm saying like
you have to have all those qualities
there so that way it all feel pays off
and i like that it's setting it up that
zachary's not just some like maniacal
kid who lusts for blood yeah yeah that
this is going to be conflicting for him
because he's going to he's going to have
some benefits from it but it's also
going to do some things to his psychosis
absolutely
absolutely i got an imdb really quick
because there's one character who showed
up who i swear looked exactly like the
doctor from the previous movie and i
think it's the same actor michael
theriot
yeah he's in the previous movie and he's
the [ __ ] girl's dad apparently ah and i
can't tell if that's supposed i don't
think it's supposed to be the same
character but it is the same actor so
what's he credited as in he's dr foley
and cult of chucky whereas here he's
just you know he's mr cross so it's
different so yeah so just a little bit
of i wanted to call it out in the
reaction and then i was like what if i'm
wrong and then you know there we go so
get away guys excited to be on board for
the show hit that like button subscribe
click that bell
john he noticed things i didn't
just like that that thing that's why
you're here man appointed
to say the things that i won't notice
you know you did it john
you did it not stressed at all about how
well i recollect every installment of
the
franchise yeah man don't stress
never stress you know the pressure
yeah
[Laughter]
of late at night cramming clone wars
[Laughter]
one of us must know this is like a show
i don't know
a show i don't have to
stress as hard
guys hey let's do a pic
adelia chamberlain delia we haven't
talked in a while
but i see the way you go off
on twitter
about people
a lot
constantly going off on twitter about
people
i wish
for your sake that this christmas
you could receive a good guy doll
one that comes to life doesn't need
batteries
that way
you can start taking care of some
problems you start taking care of some
people who just you know need to shut
the hell up
i mean do i need to say more
come on i mean you could you could why
don't you just incriminate yourself as
well why would i criminate myself
that'd be stupid yeah that would be
stupid this is going to come from an
anonymous sender of course yes yes here
on the
dumb man yeah
anonymously will receive a box to take
care of these problems and unlike this
this boy
you're not going to be conflicted no
you're going to be pretty much turning
your doll into a hitman you're going to
be giggling all the way through you're
going to be like here's a list
don't come back till it's done
don't come back till every one of them
is dead
and bring me the heads and that's why
if anyone deserves a good guy doll
it's you
good yes yes you're a sweetheart and i
know you wouldn't really do that and
i'll just keep the doll to myself
[Music]